[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
yeah it's so sad so far literally
hundreds of challengers not one winner
we don't make mistakes we don't we don't
yeah well tonight a fan with the screen
name that dark miasma
that's real later gentlemen the dark
miasma thinks he's caught a mistake he
says it happened last week when we
introduced the Royal baby to our studio
audience hey Conan I found an error in
new show
it happened when you flown the Royal
baby to your show
ladies coming back
they put it inside a balloon or a beach
ball with it whatever the hell that was
[Music]
exactly when you say you ain't supposed
to spike the Royal baby and Andy starts
talking you can actually see the baby in
the quad bike or whatever the hell that
thing is the Royal baby well we sent him
down right among the baby haters yeah I
like to see how the hell you're gonna
get out of this one
Wow yeah
I wonder who his friend is yeah I don't
want to know what that thing is all
right
dark miasma it seems you have us dead to
rights to Royal babies on the screen at
the same time means we screwed up right
wrong the baby you saw in the background
was not the Royal baby that baby was a
stalker
that's right a look-alike stalker who's
been obsessed with the Royal baby ever
since the two of them were born two
weeks ago now somehow this stalker baby
got past our tight security and got
within 30 feet of the real royal baby
you doubt me
check out this proof oh there they are
the doors are opening and there's the
royal couple
just the cutest thing ever
[Music]
[Applause]
that's proof all right okay the
challenge still stands if you think
you've spotted an error on our show
reported at team koco.com slash haha
I've found an error we will sort it out
right here on the air and we're always
very fair let's see if you've got what
it takes to make chunk meat out of the
maestro